first of all we're going to hear 51.50  from the new album 5150 is the  california code for detention of the  mentally disordered people right that's  basically the definition of it  when layman's terms have come just means  you're crazy you've never had someone do  a 5150 on you right this is not a  literal song this is a fantasy thank god  we got close a couple times but this is  from the new album machine gun kelly  with his band of excellent musicians  bruises don't heal overnight i'm a few  sips from pulling the trigger  self-abusive on the borderline but  you'll be my great digger  baby  now please please save yourself  you're crazy  you  [Music]  for the wrong reasons  [Music]  please save yourself  i hurt myself  [Music]  [Music]  please don't fix me  [Music]  this one said this  [Music]  i was jealous  i confess i'm a narcissist  [Music]  i won't go 550  you'll make me 51.50  [Music]  you  15.  [Music]  [Music]  5150  very nice boys  you